mass confusion is no doubt quite the
discussion the cdc recently announcing
those who are fully vaccinated
now have the option of not wearing a
mask thanks for joining us at six i'm
denise feldas good evening i'm brian
loftis however some businesses are not
ready to have you take that mask off
while others such as target walmart even
costco
will follow cdc guidelines and you can
take the mask off sally
live from henderson where she found many
people not really sure what exactly to
do and restaurant owners are relying
on essentially an honor system
yes brian restaurant owners tell me they
are trusting those
who are choosing to come in and dine
in here at gay tunnels restaurante on
eastern near saint rose parkway
those who are vaccinated have taken off
their mass and some
still keeping it on we've been very
compliant when it came to health codes
through the southern nevada health
district
cdc and whatnot gaetano's restaurante
owner nicholas palmary says
they have gone above and beyond this
past year to make sure
guests and employees are safe and they
will continue to do so
people have been coming still wearing
their mask and they said do we have to
wear a mask and
you know if you're vaccinated you don't
have to wear a mask
over at don tortaco rodrigo ibarra is
keeping a close eye
on how other restaurants are responding
and relying
on an honor system we're not making it
mandatory we have had some customers
like you know
come in without masks just this weekend
ivana has seen
change customers more relaxed they'll
get up without putting their mask on and
then go get their stuff and then they'll
sit down
and whether they are used to it playing
it safe or unsafe
ivara says guests are putting mass back
on after eating
i kind of feel like most people like
like everyday
people are just as confused as we are
but one thing's for sure
we don't want to make anyone
uncomfortable and when it comes to
employees taking off the mask
a mix of responses from restaurants we
as a staff are keeping it even though
we're all we are all vaccinated
as for wearing masks inside grocery
stores like smiths
that is still required in a statement
from the retail
association of nevada they tell me well
brian
wachter says as of today the county is
still requiring those masks and the
retail association recommends guidelines
should follow the science
matching the cdc's recommendation and
end confusion reporting live from
henderson
sally jaramillo 8 news now